compact SUVs are the main money spinners
for the auto industry at the moment
almost all the marks in the Fox wagon
group have made SUVs for some years now
only one did not until now
don't know mr. survived but the time has
come says our test driver Android
Zimmerman see aunt has debuted its first
SUV it's called the attacker and is
based on vw's nqb modular platform that
means many components have been tried
and tested and are already used in other
models so he's curious to see how the
Spanish cousin of the VW tiguan performs
we are testing the top of the line
version excellence it comes with
climatronic media system plus with
8-inch display a range of driving modes
and a rear view camera equipped with the
most powerful engine it costs about 35
and a half thousand euros in Germany
4,000 euros less than the
top-of-the-line VW tiguan with the same
engine
once I test fog our test car has a
2-liter diesel engine it is a bit lame
under 2,000 rpm but beyond that it comes
into its own the 400 Newton meter talk
is certainly a match for the weight of
the vehicle see at says consumption is 5
liters 400 kilometers but most drivers
won't get that seven liters is more
realistic I'll order probably middlin
the attacker is one of several SUVs in
the VW Group with a four-wheel drive
system that distributes power to the
front and rear axles as needed
the attacker has the typical look of a
sea at full LED headlights are available
it's sharp exterior lines look lean and
dynamic
the trunk is spacious the rear seats are
oh me too you don't have to be a
subcompact person to feel at ease the
dashboard resembles that of the sea at
Leon the start button blinks like a
heartbeat desi the Atika is based on the
Leon and it is of course very similar to
the VW Golf so it's no surprise that the
attacker drives like you would expect it
to personate he'd like just a tad more
sportiness like we see in other sea at
models that's because of its higher
center of gravity but the Atika makes up
for that with its excellent suspension
that evens out even big bumps in the
road on global on em hidin zob evicted
em c at is offering various assist
systems with the MQB program traffic jam
assist is one option it helps handle
stopping and starting during congestion
an absolute own real highlight is the
emergency brake assistant which is
standard in all the versions of course
you hope you never need it but it is
good to know that it's there should your
concentration lapse for a moment who
says opposes good citizen that's burning
hat photo on manage cancer off Maxim is
the latest version of the city emergency
brake function recognizes pedestrians as
well as cars it's a useful feature for
motoring in town the rearview mirrors
are large an optional extra is a blind
spot assistant it helps ensure you don't
overlook any vehicles as you turn or
change lanes the attacker is a true
sports utility vehicle an all-rounder
that fulfills its purpose wherever you
are
ancona it's a small step for the auto
industries as Andre but a huge step for
see at the attacker doesn't have any
weak spots it's spacious and it drives
well the entry-level model price of
20,000 euros in Germany is extremely
competitive for him the Atika looks
better than the to go I finishes to
Attica the sooner the tiguan
the Mercedes cup in stood guard is part
of the ATP World Tour the focus today is
not only on tennis but also on cars the
cups main sponsor mercedes-benz is using
the occasion to present the sixth
generation of its midsize station wagon
variants the e-class t-model tennis pro
Roger Federer provides VIP testimony
spits and for the best though he admits
that as a top athlete he's more
interested in supercars and AMG but he
thinks these t models are pretty
incredible too plenty of luxury inside
and a great look and they're very
practical and functional epoch digits us
cancer fontanilla the new generation is
also stuffed full of electronics that
make driving safer and more comfortable
your hubby Mercedes board member oh la
colonias says all the innovative
technology developed for the e-class has
been put into the T model as well with
the drive pilot first step has been
taken toward the self-driving car in
some situations that car can take over
the driving another important criterion
in a station wagon is the trunk and it's
very large in the new e-class 640 liters
fit in normally if you load up the car
to the roof you get 1820 litres the
equivalent of 12,000 tennis balls the
back seat can be folded down comfortably
that's still not as much as the
predecessors 1950 liters but that's the
trade-off for a much slimmer sporty-er
exterior
in the marlin Benitez's roger federer
says he sat in the new station wagon and
was very impressed with the interior
especially the various kinds of leather
as a top athlete he's going to stick
with the AMG says but the station wagon
too has good styling is a bit more
aggressive and has more power than its
predecessor the sporty AMG version of
this family car gets 295 kilowatts from
its 3 liter engine more than enough to
go shopping or on vacation with the
whole family an optimized 9-speed
automatic transmission provides all four
wheels with plenty of power
but there's also a station wagon with a
hundred and ten kilowatts and a more
family-friendly price though we're still
talking about forty eight thousand euros
in Germany not every e-class buyer is
also a top athlete
volvo hopes to shake up the luxury car
market with the elegant lines and power
of its new s90 it's the second model
after the second generation xc90 SUV to
be based on volvo scalable architecture
platform the s90 has a base price of 42
thousand seven hundred and fifty euros
in Germany the Fiat 124 spider brings an
Italian legend back to life fifty years
after the legendary Fiat 124 sport
spider took to the roads the new spider
brings back bad authentic roadster
feeling and combines it with the umph of
a modern sports car that's supplied by a
1.4 liter turbo engine with multi air
technology
in borussia dortmund soccer stadium the
Bundesliga summer break is being used to
repair and shape up the playing field
that doesn't bother our car tester
Michelle Assenmacher she's not here for
a match but to check out the seats seats
in a stadium are not built for comfort
and after a game people often drive home
and car seats are often not much better
Michelle is on a quest for the perfect
seat
opal has the solution she says in 2003
the seats in opals insignia with the
first car seats to be commended by the
experts at the axiom gesund awoken a
foul a german organization devoted to
healthy spines today many opel models
have its approval not only for the
driver's seat but also the passenger
seat as well
a corrected stable sitting position is
especially important if you have an
accident on long trips the seat support
for the spine should be individually
adjusted enabling the muscles to work
optimally the second generation of
certified economic seats is now equipped
with massage and ventilation functions
unlike soccer stadium seats
then china's physiotherapist Susan Fonda
heiden explains that a typical bucket
seat is molded in one piece and cannot
be adjusted an ergonomic seat enables
active flexible sitting in a stadium no
fans sit still for more than five
minutes they're constantly in motion but
in a car seat of person sits relatively
passively so these ergonomic seats can
be adjusted in many ways tailored to
people's individuality and especially to
their spine unlike a seat in a stadium
given shinobi of the encinitas captain
gives out some French to some stallions
true adjusting the seat begins with the
right distance between the sitting
surface and the pedals the right seat
height determines the drivers viewing
position and optimum field of vision the
back of the seat supports upright
posture making it more comfortable to
hold the steering wheel
tilting the seat reduces pressure on the
bones you sit on and the distance from
the pedals can be adjusted to suit the
length of your lower legs the sitting
surface of the ergonomic seats can be
lengthened or shortened to fit the legs
of tall or short people support in the
lower back is crucial for optimal
backbone mobility and hear the new seats
offer not only lumbar support but also a
massage function the back and sides of
the seat and the sitting surface can
also be adjusted to meet individual
needs
after plenty of briefing about proper
sitting positions michele puts it all to
test in the new Opel Astra economic
seats are available in this model is an
option for 390 euros in Germany of
course it takes a few moments to make
all the adjustments but the time and
effort are worth it the new memory
function can save the individual
preferences of two people
ergonomic seats are less tiring for a
driver especially on long trips that
Michelle notice is one thing almost
immediately
dear son first impression of the Astra's
economic seat is very favorable and
certainly better than a soccer stadium
seat the seats massage function pumps
air into and back out of the area behind
your lower back and at about the middle
of your back that's very pleasant and
relaxing but after about ten minutes
it's more than enough so Michelle turns
across the aim of the massage function
is to improve circulation and thus
concentration on long trips
does the best undies what Michelle likes
best about this seat is that it can be
adjusted individually you can improve
the lateral support and the seat length
and avoid having your legs fall asleep
Michelle says she's really surprised at
how good opals ergonomic seats feel and
she can imagine driving long distances
in comfort lot of excellent how does
opal plan to continue developing its
seats geldim abuses andrew largeman
opals senior manager of seat engineering
says a car seat is extremely complex and
one of the most expensive parts in the
whole car ten percent of production
costs go into the seats car seat
development is tremendously dynamic and
opal is working on a number of
improvements in the areas of safety
functionality and design with everything
his department has in the pipeline his
job is far from boring and it's not feel
of us viewers over the end up i plan on
in the future opal wants to shave weight
from the seats as well and if driving to
the soccer match is so comfortable maybe
someday we'll see fans carrying their
seats into the stadium
for over 40 years the pono has been one
of Volkswagens top sellers for five
generations little VW as always moved
with the times the design of the polo is
modern and timeless it's become more
fuel-efficient thanks to bluemotion
technology VW has also given the Polo a
wide range of comfort and safety
equipment Quonset lachemann a la carte
estimate is kool ad says you don't have
to compromise very much if you decide on
a car like the VW Polo there's a
navigation system automatic air
conditioning a multifunction steering
wheel electric windows and power mirrors
but there are still a few points where
you notice you're sitting in a small car
for example the seats are slightly
shorter than in the Gulf so if you're
tall or going on a long journey it's
just not quite as comfortable and it's
simply noisier inside than in a larger
vehicle by an employer on fat like the
polo has a multi collision break as
standard it's meant to prevent one
accident from causing another automatic
distance control is optional as is front
assist which helps avoid collisions with
traffic ahead through a radar sensor in
the lower air intake in Germany this
safety feature can be had for an
additional charge of 515 euros it's
cutting-edge technology that not every
car maker offers in this class
for your heart for the other matter says
we w's previous diesel engines produce
66 kilowatts from 1.9 liters now it's
1.4 liter engines can do the same job
but the noise level is somehow stayed
the same let's take a look at the
technical data of our 66 kilowatt 1.4
liter TDI VW says it's very fuel
efficient and consumes only three point
six liters of diesel per 100 kilometers
its acceleration of 10.9 seconds from 0
to 100 km/h doesn't sound so spectacular
but it has pulling power reaching
maximum torque of 230 Newton meters at
only 1750 rpm matter says that although
a 1.4 is a relatively small engine for a
diesel it has plenty of low-end torque
and that deserves respect because it's
something a lot of much larger engines
don't have D does less there in the
common the infotainment system in the
Polo offers the same technology that is
available in the Gulf our test car is
equipped with the sport select
suspension this allows a choice of two
different levels of ride firmness just
by pressing a button
I taught you about matt it says when the
first VW Polo came on the market over 40
years ago it was not only significantly
smaller but its craftsmanship was
significantly worse there's no longer
any sign of that today it has a padded
dashboard which she says is always very
important the steering wheel fits very
comfortably in your hand the seats
provide good back support not just
around town but even on longer journeys
new atlantis kilometers off sits in
camps on and off my spy wounded
therefore we pull with me he says the VW
polo is certainly not the peppiest small
car on the market but it is probably one
of the small cars that's easiest to get
used to thanks to the logical VW
controls developed over many years which
aren't very easy to understand you don't
need an advanced degree to drive away or
to operate all the important functions
one I love thee Stephen for torrents of
the deer the current polo is already two
years old BTW is working on its
successor and will unveil the 6th
generation parlor at the geneva motor
show in the spring it's set to add even
more new technology including a parking
and congestion assistant
meet the BMW 503 cabriolet a car that
wowed car lovers it was the first German
car with an electric soft-top as
standard equipment its chassis was
entirely an aluminium it was the first
mass-produced car with a light alloy v8
engine and the sound was music to the
air
in 1956 BMW brought out the company's
most expensive model up till then the
503 in the coop a and convertible
versions each sold for twenty nine
thousand five hundred marks the price of
a single-family home Michelle pitch-off
has owned his 503 Cabriolet for many
years now and he's still thrilled by it
miyamoto he invites us to imagine it's
1956 just 11 years after the end of
World War two suddenly there's the first
car with a v8 engine and 150 horsepower
and it can go 190 kilometers an hour
that stacked up to the mercedes 300sl
with its gullwing doors which was a
gigantic car there really wasn't much
else like it in Germany at the time for
him the 503 still tops it all so quickly
any shall Wayne ain't Hoover outdoor
them at this will be technically the 503
Cabriolet was a luxury car for factory
owners and film stars wealthy
industrialists like count faber castell
and rudolf al ghost etka drove them in
the 1950s the elegant two-door model
took home gold medals from car shows in
can roam Lisbon and Vienna
absolute Michele push off wax is
enthusiastic about the car's power
comfort and size the technology is
simple nicer than in modern cars the 503
holds four people comfortably making it
great for holidays and that's without
sacrificing sportiness the only thing to
slow him down is when there's traffic on
the road them with any forgive the
aluminium chassis was built by the
chassis specialist company Bauer inch
stood guard the design didn't follow any
trends from abroad BMW came up with it
on its own the 503 marked a turning
point in BMW design a shift from pre-war
tastes to a leaner and more modern look
the understated pontoon shape did
without flashy effects and followed the
ideal proportions of a Gran Turismo car
a long hood and a short rear end
in its technology the 503 was based on
the big BMW sedans the 501 and 502 the
frame engine transmission and axles were
almost identical the interior is
impressive too with its clean beauty and
1950s aesthetics three round gauges
inlaid in a metal dashboard and a few
ivory colored buttons in 1956 this was
the state-of-the-art luxury
but the 503 came at a difficult time for
BMW few people in post-war Germany could
afford such exclusive cars BMW produced
only 139 of the convertible version over
the course of five years by the late
1950s BMW was on the verge of bankruptcy
the company rescued itself with small
cars like the Zetas and the BMW 700 but
of course they didn't have the luxury or
the power of a 503 the engine the
world's first cast aluminium v8 was a
masterpiece of German engineering two
carburetors ferret fuel later versions
had outputs of 119 kilowatts at the time
even Mercedes was offering only
six-cylinder engines
today a 503 convertible in good shape
will set you back a quarter of a million
euros when it comes to vintage cars
BMW's 503 is a crown jewel